on estime qu'il faut soumettre la
collectivité la communauté au
subjectivité qui plus est au
subjectivité minoritaires quant aux
villes écrit dans la démocratie en
amérique que la démocratie est une
catastrophe parce que c'est de la
tyrannie des mines des majorités de la
majorité jeudi mais ce serait formidable
qu'on ait la tyrannie de la majorité
or là on à la tyrannie des minorités je
ne dis pas que les transsexuels n'existe
pas et ne devrait pas exister ou que
c'est une anomalie coûts etc etc je dis
qu'ils sont minoritaires et qu' ils ont
droit à un traitement de faveur
bien sûr mais sans imaginer que cette
minorité devrait pouvoir devenir une
majorité
je pense que c'est la même chose avec
tout ce qui a été marges chez les
philosophes de la déconstruction ça pu
être chez deleuze schizophrène chez
foucault le fou larmes aphrodite aussi
chez foucault le prisonnier chez
foucault également on a estimé que d'un
seul coup il fallait en finir avec le
centre de la page et faire de telle
sorte que les mages les marges devienne
le centre
je ne suis pas de ceux qui disent que
c'était bien que le centre ignore les
marges mais je pense que les marges
ignorant le centre c'est pas bien non
plus il faudrait donc faire de telle
sorte qu'on puisse avoir un équilibre
entre eux les marges et le centre pour
faire de telle sorte que chacun puisse
trouver l'occasion de fabriquer une
communauté nous ne fabriquons plus de
communauté on est dans une somme de deux
lotissements corps que l'autisme
l'utilisation du mot va m'être reprochée
mais de solipsisme je dirais et une
somme de solipsisme chacun étant lui
même sa propre femme rangée bien droit
je veux bien
j'envie le matin de me réveiller comme
un garçon le midi d'être une fille
l'après-midi éventuellement de changer
depuis le square d'être dans la
détermination et j'ai bien le droit de
ça et parfois on agresse le prof à qui
elle a dit non ne m'appelez pas monsieur
je suis madame et qui appelle madame
quelqu'un qui décide dans l'après midi
qu'il est devenu neutre était le soir re
demandera qu'on l'appelle madame etc il
ya un moment donné où les caprices
solipsiste ne peuvent pas faire la loi
d'une collectivité ou d'une communauté
on enseignait jadis qu'il n'y avait pas
de subjectivité mais que de la
communauté
aujourd'hui on enseigne inverse il n'y a
que des subjectivités et aucune
communauté
à
[Musique]